So, what I want to do here is, take a
look at how we would go about auditing our street
names or our names for ways in such a way
that we can get a sense for what's going to need
to be fixed here? All right? So, let me walk
you through this code in detail. This is a modified
version of the code we looked at back in Lesson
Three. And what we're doing here is using ElementTree, the C
version, and if we scroll down, this is actually one
of the more interesting parts of this code. So let's, let's
take it one step at a time. So here, we're
using iterparse, part of the ElementTree module. Okay. And a couple
of things I want to point out here. Again, remember that
this data set is enormous, almost 2 gigabytes. So, we can't
read the whole thing into memory as an XML tree
or an element tree. Rather, what we have to do is,
iteratively parse it or parse it using event-based parsing
and you can see some of that language coming
out here. Essentially, the way iterparse works is, every
time it sees one of the events that we've
specified here, it is going to emit the event
and the element that it found, okay? So, let
me break that down in terms of the data
specifically. The way I've set this code up is
anytime it sees a start tag, okay, that's
what this says here All right? And to events,
we actually have to pass it a tuple.
Okay? We can pass it any number of recognized
events. But, in this case, I'm only concerned
with getting start tag events. So I just want
iterparse to generate the next item in its iteration
when it sees a start tag. And in Python,
we need to end tuples with the comma, okay, so make
sure you do that if you're going to use code like this. Okay,
and then what I'm saying here in the next line is, all
right, if that element you kicked out to me, again remember, this
is a tag, so this is going to be an object representation,
a Python object that essentially represents some sort of start tag, a
node, or a way, or a relation, or maybe member here. Okay.
And then what I'm doing here is I'm filtering. I'm saying, okay.
The tag property for this element object that you kicked out, has to be "way",
that has to be the value of it. Okay, if that's the case, then what I want to do
is for that element, I want to call
the iter method, okay? Now, the iter method is
designed so that it will return in an
iteration all of the sub tags, the tags nested
within this particular element, whatever that is. So,
going back to the documentation here. It would give
me back, for this particular start tag, each
and every one of the tags that are nested
within it. Okay? I can optionally specify to
the iter method. The value of a particular tag
that I would like to get back, and what
this does then is modifies the behavior of iter.
So that rather than giving me back all of the tags that are nested
within a particular start tag, it will just give me those that, are named,
according to the constraint that I've specified,
so here, I've said, just give me
back those that are "tag" tags. Okay? So I would just get back these.